Hello. Good afternoon. We're going to get started.
Welcome, and thank you for joining us.
I'm Montse Garcia-Closas from the Institute of Cancer Research in
London, and I'll be co-chairing this session with Dr.
Tesia Patil from the University of Colorado.
And there are quite a few of you online,
so we're going to leave this QR code
so that you have a chance to capture it, and that will be the way
that people can ask questions online.
Okay.
Yeah. So then we'll
get started.
Okay, so we are going to hear
seven talks. Their unifying theme is
that they are trying to identify biomarkers that can actually make a
difference and change management of patients, and make a difference for the care of
patients.
And they cover a wide range of areas and techniques,
and they go through the cancer continuum from biomarkers for early
detection, diagnosis, treatment, as well as all the way to survivorship.
We're actually going to start with
the first talk is going to be actually at the end of this continuum in
survivorship, looking at whole genome doubling as a
predictor for cancer metastasis.
And then we'll have four talks that are
presenting data on predictive and prognostic biomarkers.
And they're using a range of techniques like tissue-based
homologous recombination deficiency status, multi-omics
approaches for therapeutic options
for hepatocellular carcinoma,
stromal immune profiling in the context of recurrence
from polyps and progression to colorectal cancer, as well as
using whole exome sequencing base, also the HDR
score,
to
make treatment decisions on PARP inhibitors in ovarian
cancer.
And then the last two talks are focused more on early detection
biomarkers, including CA 19-9 for
early onset diabetes as a window for prediction of
pancreatic cancer and spatial biology and AI for early
melanoma detection. So you can see that we're going to hear from across
multiple techniques and
markers that are relevant for different wide range of cancers.
And what we are going to try to
hear from the talks is how close are we on
the translation of these biomarkers in the clinical practice and making
a difference.
So without further ado, we're going to hear from the first speaker,
Dr. Hu from Memorial Sloan Kettering, and he's going to talk
about the
whole genome duplication as a predictor of metastasis for pan-cancer
predictor. Thank you.
So thanks for the introduction. It's a great honor to be here today to present our
research using large-scale clinical genomic data to show the
relationship between whole genome duplication and a patient's metastatic
risk.
So, showing the following plot below, you can see at the cell level,
the tumor on the left after whole genome doubling exactly have their
chromosome doubles showing on the right.
So computationally, it was shown in a 2018 paper from our
lab that you're able to infer whole genome doubling by
calculating the proportion of the autosomal genome with major copy number
greater or equal to two. What was also shown in
that paper was that those metastatic samples, they tend to have
a significantly higher amount of whole genome doubling, indicating that
WGD is related to more advanced disease.
So in more recent studies, here I'm showing a 2023 paper published by
MSK. When we're looking at non-small cell lung cancer, those
primary tumors that ever develop a metastasis compared to those primary
tumors that never develop a metastasis, there's a significantly higher amount of
whole genome doubling. And in a more recent study published last
year using a match primary and matched sample analysis,
it was shown that WGD is the most common gain of event
across all the genomic events, indicating that there is a further
relationship between whole genome doubling and metastasis.
So we're interested in a slightly different question.
So all those studies have shown that in the metastatic sample, you're more
likely to have a whole genome doubling.
But what if a patient, when it arrives at MSK, their
primary tumor has a whole genome doubling?
So in those early-stage patients who never have a metastasis, whether whole
genome doubling status in that primary tumor will predict a
patient's future chance of ever developing metastasis.
So to answer that question, we start with the MSK50K data.
So that study was currently publicly available, just published last
month. Feel free to scan the QR code to have a better understanding.
But basically, we limit the analysis to those that have good quality copy number
calls, and we remove those stage four patients and limit the analysis to
those early-stage patients and arrive around 14,000
samples in the end.
So to get the metastatic status for those patients, so
here we utilize machine learning models to
infer a patient's metastatic event based on the radiology report.
And all those data are based on MSK-CORD, which was developed by Dr.
Justin Jeeves and his team and published in 2024.
So to give you an example here, let's say a patient, non-small cell lung
cancer, early stage, arrive at MSK at this time.
So after a certain amount of time, their primary sample was acquired and
then sequenced with MSK Impact.
Later on, based on the radiology report, we're able to get the
metastatic event for those patients.
So we not only know where those patients have a metastasis,
in this case there's a liver and a brain met and then a liver met, and we also know
the timing of each of the events for some of the further
analysis.So the first thing we look at is what
proportion of those primary never MET early-stage
tumors harbor whole genome doubling.
And what we see is that that proportion is around one-fourth
pan-cancer-wise, around 22%. Of course, that proportion
changes a lot depending on the cancer type you're looking at.
So in esophageal gastric or colorectal cancer, where there's
a higher amount of global aneuploidy, you see that proportion to be higher in
the primary tumor, while in some of the tumors that tend to be more
globally less aneuploidy like glioma, that proportion is only around 10%.
So the first thing we look at is to validate if the metastatic calling we
have aligns with previous research findings.
And to answer that question, here we break down the tumors into three
group. So the first group is those primary tumors that never have a
metastasis, and there's also a sufficient amount of follow-up.
In this case, we define as 24 months, so two years from the sample
acquisition. The second group we look at is those primary
tumors that have early metastasis defined as having a metastasis in the first
year. And finally, is those metastatic samples.
What you can see is that pan-cancer wise, we see a significantly
higher amount of whole genome doubling in those primary early MET compared to the
primary never MET, and also aligned with previous findings, those metastatic
samples have the highest proportion.
And when you look at a cancer type specific level, you still see that
consistent trend, which those primary early MET samples have a
significantly higher amount of whole genome doubling compared to those primary
never MET samples, which is the lightest color.
So the next question to answer our hypothesis directly,
we broke down the tumors on the left I'm showing those non whole genome doubled
tumors, on the right are those whole genome doubled tumors.
And we calculate the proportion of tumors that ever develop a
metastasis. In this case, you could see that those whole genome doubled tumors,
patients actually are more likely to develop a metastasis compared to those
non whole genome doubled cases. And when you look at a cancer type
specific level, you still see that consistent trend.
And I here want to specifically highlight breast cancer, where that difference is
more drastic, which those whole genome doubled tumors is twice as likely
as ever developing a metastasis compared to those non whole genome
doubled cases.
So the next question we want to ask is, we see there's a higher
chance of ever developing a metastasis, but what about the metastatic
burden? And in this case, we use a landmark analysis.
So basically we take all the patient, and then we take a snapshot
at that one year, and we just count the number of unique
metastatic site within the first year of primary sample
acquisition. And in this case, you could see that those whole genome doubled
tumors not only has a higher chance of ever developing a metastasis,
but they also tend to have more metastatic sites.
So in this case, a greater or equal to two sites or three sites.
And again, when you look at cancer type specific trends, you still see
that consistent trend where those whole genome doubled tumors are more
likely to have a higher metastatic burden.
So the first thing we look at is what proportion of those primary never MET
early-stage tumors harbor whole genome doubling.
And what we see is that that proportion is around one-fourth pan-cancer-wise,
around 22%. Of course, that proportion changes a lot depending on the cancer type
you're looking at. So in esophageal gastric or colorectal cancer, where there's a
higher amount of global aneuploidy, you see that proportion to be higher in the
primary tumor, while in some of the tumors that tend to be more globally less
aneuploidy like glioma, that proportion is only around 10%.
So the first thing we look at is to validate if the metastatic calling we have
aligns with previous research findings.
And to answer that question, here we break down the tumors into three group.
So the next question we ask is, is there a certain pattern that those whole genome
doubled tumors tend to metastasize to?
Is there a certain site of a preference?
So given the limited time today, I'm only going to show you the results on
brain metastasis. So in this case, we still do a landmark
analysis. So we calculate the proportion of patient who develop a
brain MET at one year. And in this case you could see pan-cancer wise,
those whole genome doubled tumors is twice as likely to ever
develop a brain MET. And in the non-small cell lung cancer
case, that proportion becomes 2.5x, indicating
that those whole genome doubled tumors not only are more likely to ever develop
a MET, have a higher metastatic burden, but they also tend to develop
metastasis to those harder-to-treat sites, and that could potentially
explain why they have a worse prognostic in the patient treatment
outcome in the long term.
So I think the final key question we want to ask is, is everything we see
independent of TP53? So it's pretty much well known that a lot of
those whole genome doubled tumors, they harbor a P53 alteration,
and they also have an elevated amount of aneuploidy.
So here we're trying to answer if we still see that effect when we stratify by
P53 status. And in this case, you could clearly
see that in both the P53 wild type and the
TP53 altered patients, we always see those whole genome doubled
tumors having a higher metastatic incidence.
And what is more interesting is that if you overlay those four lines together,
you see that the black line here, so those whole genome double positive
P53 wild type, they have a similar effect in
terms of the increased metastatic risk as those whole genome double negative
TP53 mutant cases, indicating that in those
P53 wild type tumors, when you have a whole genome doubling,
it brings a similar effect in metastatic risk as if the
tumor has a P53 alteration.
So I hope today's talk, I'm able to persuade you that whole genome
doubling emerges as a promising biomarker for early
stage never MET primary patients, and could be
used to predict a patient's future chance of ever developing
metastasis. I showed you that those whole genome doubled tumors
not only have a higher chance of ever developing a metastasis, they also
tend to have a higher metastatic burden and also has a certain pattern to
develop metastasis to those more hard-to-treat sites, indicating worse
prognostic in the long term.
Finally, I show that this effect we see on whole genome doubling on
metastasis risk is independent of TP53
status.
So in the end, I really want to thank my lab, especially my PI, Dr.
Nikki Showe, and also my mentor, Henry and Waleed.
I also want to thank all the collaborators across MSK, and especially the patients
who contribute that data to make this study possible.
And I'm happy to take any questions. Thank you.
Okay. Hi. Kate Nathanson, University of Pennsylvania.
I noticed you actually excluded the tumor type with the
highest frequency of whole genome doubling, testicular cancer.
And I wanted to know if you would comment, given
that obviously it's not necessarily at high rate for metastatic-
Yep.
-disease, but it has a very high rate of whole genome doubling.
If you would comment on why you excluded it from your analysis.
Yes.
And what do you think the implications are, given it
probably does not completely support this hypothesis. I don't know.
Yes.
You would know better, whether or not it supports this hypothesis.
Yes, so that's a great question. So actually, in the cohort selection slide,
I have a slide that I skipped. But
we only keep those tumor types where we have enough
samples in both the non whole genome doubled and also the whole genome double case.
And when you limit it to the primarily early-stage patients,
most of the patients treated as MSK are stage four, so you're already limiting a
smaller population. And especially for those tumor types, so in our case,
we're seeing a germ cell tumor also has a very high proportion of WGD.
There's not enough sample type in those non whole genome double case.
So when we want to compare the metastatic risk
between by a binary factor, which is whole genome doubling here, it's being
removed. And
here we define at least 20
patients with at least two years of follow-up.
So if it doesn't meet that criteria, that cancer type will be removed in the
downstream analysis. So, I think to that question, we should definitely
look into that cancer type specifically, even though it's being removed, maybe due
to small sample size. And I think that's a great question.
At least in germ cell tumor, we do see WGD itself is not a
predictor of metastasis.
Mm-hmm.
And also, if I go further, I think there's ovarian cancer.
It's also not a good predictor of metastasis.
I think it depends really on the tumor type.
It's only when in those tumors that not tend to have a global
large amount of aneuploidy, that effect becomes more significant.
Like in breast, we know it's triple negative breast cancer, but in ovarian, you
actually even see the reverse trends. But I think that's a wonderful question.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. Andy Grossgarden.
So do you have enough data to break out
increasing tumor ploidy or
how much of the genome ends up in LOH, right?
Yes.
Are those explaining versus the doubling rate, or can you
break it out further that way or so?
Yeah. So actually, in last year's ACR, I present a little bit
on where we look at colorectal cancer, and then
we did a very comprehensive look on the copy number landscape of those tumors.
So I could say we have the segmentation level copy
number profile of each of those tumors. So we actually...
I'm not showing it here today, but feel free to come after the talk.
I'm happy to share the results. But we look at the ploidy, the loss
of heterozygosity of the tumor, and also the copy number state of those
tumors. What I could say is that those whole genome double tumors,
they're very interesting. They're actually not really tetraploid,
showing at the very beginning where in
the cell level you could see it's exactly four.
Actually, computationally, we see they're mostly triploid.
And also, they have certain copy number patterns, and in the end, they're
pretty stable. So after a certain amount of evolution,
they have a lot of aneuploidy, but they don't really change after that.
But yeah, I'm happy to share more results if you're interested in the
specific copy number part.
Cool. Thank you.
Great. Mm-hmm.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
I'd like to introduce our next speaker,
Pegah Safabakhsh, who will be talking about tissue-based
homologous recombination deficiency status prediction in
patients with breast, ovarian, and pancreatic cancers.
Hi, everyone. Thank you for the opportunity here.
As mentioned, we're going to be talking about a genomic instability status
prediction method in a tissue-based platform for breast,
ovarian, and pancreatic cancer.
These are my relevant financial disclosures.
So just a bit of background on HRD, or homologous recombination
deficiency. This is a molecular phenotype that's
characterized by the inability to
repair DNA double-stranded stranded breaks.
Identifying these HRD tumors could help select patients that
can benefit from DNA damage repair targeting therapies such as PARP
inhibitors, and this is through synthetic lethality.
HRD can lead to genomic instability, so this is detectable
by targeted sequencing, and this can theoretically help identify
a larger group of patients that might benefit from this therapy beyond just looking
at BRCA1 and 2 or HRR gene mutations.
So the method that we've developed is based on using the Guardant
360 tissue platform. So this is a targeted next-gen sequencing assay.
This profiles 741 cancer-associated genes.
We do a full genomic profiling, including SNVs, indels, copy number
alterations, fusions. There's also methylation profiling and
whole transcriptome sequencing.
So all of these would be profiled along with GIS or HRD.
And this is the schema of the model that we've developed.
So, a given sample is profiled on Guardant 360 tissue.
We run it through a bioinformatics pipeline that does all the genomic variant
calling, and we determine if the sample has a sufficient number
of SNVs to basically apply
a SNV signature prediction to it.
If there are insufficient SNVs detected in the sample, then we
employ the model on the bottom. So it's either including a CNV-based
signature model or a model that includes both SBS or single-base
substitution, along with copy number-based signatures.
So together, these make an ensemble model.That produces a
probabilistic score of being HRD, to which we apply a
threshold that gives us a binary genomic instability status.
The model was trained and validated using breast, ovarian, and pancreatic clinical
samples that were tested on Guardant360 tissue.
We used genomic labels based on biallelic loss in
BRCA1 and 2 being HRD positive.
And HRD negative or HRD proficient would be HRR wild type.
So the absence of any genomic alterations in
a larger list of 14 HRR genes that are listed at the bottom,
as well as promoter methylation, which would also be excluded.
And
we use these as orthogonal HRD labels.
So in summary, the GIS on Guardant360 tissue or genomic instability
status is a probabilistic HRD prediction approach that we've developed
using a combination of CNV and SNV-based biomarkers.
So to dive a bit deeper into the SNV signature component,
we looked at a
set of published signatures from COSMIC that we selected
a subset of for inclusion in the model.
So we basically looked at each sample's SNVs that
were detected and can develop a projection score
using the SBS signatures from COSMIC.
And then we looked at the differences between our HRD negative and
positive labels to identify signatures that were statistically different
between those two groups. And so on the right, we're showing
the box plot of the scores that we derived from our training samples.
And we see that
the first two signatures identified on the left are commonly
associated with HRD, SBS3 and SBS39.
And just also want to remind that this is a targeted panel, so these
were typically derived from whole genome sequencing.
And so the fact that we were able to detect these signatures
was a great thing to see. And we also
detected two other signatures that were associated with deficient mismatch
repair, so SBS6 and SBS15.
The SBS3 and SBS39 were increased in BRCA biallelic samples
as compared to HR wild type, and mismatch repair
deficiency signatures were decreased in BRCA biallelic samples.
So this is consistent with the idea that dmmr and
HRD are generally mutually exclusive.
We also detected SBS5, which is a clock-like signature, but
the decrease in BRCA biallelic was also seen, but it was to a much lesser extent
than we saw in dmmr.
So in terms of the overall model accuracy, we were able to
achieve an AUC of 0.98 in a test cohort of
164 Guardant360 clinical samples, and
the ROC curve on the right is shown.
For sensitivity assessment, we looked at the positive detection rate in
BRCA1 and 2 biallelic loss samples in the same test cohort.
We also looked at a smaller independent AV cohort of 31 samples.
The results are shown at the bottom.
We were able to achieve 88% to 96% sensitivity in ovarian,
78% to 96% in breast, and 80% in pancreatic.
For specificity, we estimated this looking at the HR wild type group.
So we looked at negative percent agreement or NPA, and we had
100% across most of the cohorts, with one pancreatic cohort
coming in at 93%.
You'll notice that we included one cohort that were non-HRD,
typically HRD cancer types, colorectal, esophageal, gastric,
bladder, and bile duct. This was to supplement the cohort given the
relatively low prevalence of HR wild type samples amongst ovarian, breast, and
pancreatic. And in that cohort, we also observed 100%
specificity.
So to look at the landscape of GIS, we looked
at a cohort of clinical Guardant360 tissue samples,
and we first looked at the overall prevalence.
So we found that we were able to detect GIS in about a third of
breast samples, 45% of ovarian samples, and about
14% of pancreatic samples.
So we've broken those down by patients that have GIS
detected, as well as BRCA1 and 2 pathogenic mutations.
And then the middle blue color identifies the patients that would not
typically be
recommended for DDR targeting therapies that have
HRR alterations but are not necessarily pathogenic.
And so we
observed that about half the cases across the cancer types
were
overlapping with BRCA1 and 2 pathogenic mutations.
And so this middle blue color represents this expanded patient
population for therapy selection.
These are the patients that do not have BRCA1 and 2 pathogenic
mutations.
Within that group, we also looked at
more clear potential drivers that could be driving
GIS in terms of pathogenic mutations in non-BRCA1 and
2. But we found that only about 2% to 3% of ovarian and breast
patients could be attributed to that genotype.
So
we still think that there's a benefit to using GIS to
identify these patients that would not have been captured by
deleterious HRR mutations.
So to wrap up, here today we showed a genomic instability
status method, GIS, on Guardant360 tissue.
This was a probabilistic model that we developed on SNV and CNV-based
signatures to predict HRD status in breast, pancreatic, and ovarian cancer with
high accuracy.
This displays the utility for potentially broadening the identification of
patients who might benefit from DDR-targeting therapies beyond
conventional HRG mutation
testing.We also wanted to highlight
that we have GIS available in Guardant360 Liquid.
And so patients that in our profile with both liquid and tissue assays on
Guardant360 can now be comprehensively monitored for HRD
using a combination of these two assays.
For some of our future work,
we recognize that prostate cancer also has a great ability
to-- GIS can have a great ability to expand patient selection
for prostate cancer.
In our initial development work, we've
observed a distinct genomic scarring signature in prostate, suggesting
that a cancer-specific model will be needed, and we're currently
developing that. It's in progress.
And of course, we want to clinically validate this as a predictive
biomarker in patients that are treated with DDR targeting
therapies such as PARP inhibitors.
And that's all I have. Thank you.
At this point, we'd like to open it up to the audience for questions.
I have one for you. Your model identifies
many HRD positive tumors, and they extend beyond
just BRCA mutations.
When we think about PARP selection,
how do you envision this sort of playing out in clinical practice and in clinical
trial design?
Yeah. So we envision a BRCA or
GIS type model,
which has been employed by Myriad, which was approved for ovarian
cancer in the past. I think we see that BRCA is an
established selection biomarker, and so we don't want to override that.
We think there could be potential for GIS to help distinguish
better responders within BRCA. That doesn't always have a particularly high
response rate, depending on the indication and the drug.
But that is still out for debate and requires a
lot of future validation data to show that type of
application. So,
in the near future, we see it as a complement to
HR gene profiling.
Guardant360 tissue also has methylation profiling, so we think
BRCA1 promoter methylation can also help supplement
patient selection there. But for the time being, we see it as
GIS or HR gene mutation kind of
selection logic.
I have another question. So can you comment on, are
there any other assays that have been
developed, also sequencing-based,
for the signature and the advantages of the assay that you've been
using compared to others?
Yeah. So Guardant360 tissue is a relatively new
platform.
And so we haven't had a chance to compare it to orthogonal assays yet.
But I think one major advantage we have is that it's a relatively large
gene panel. We have full coverage of BRCA1 and 2.
We capture large deletions, rearrangements, reversions,
promoter methylation. So all of these things can be captured at the same time as
HRD.
But in terms of
predictive benefit in a clinical trial or with on-target therapies,
that's to be determined. But there are definitely other
assays that have
shown that already. So we're hoping to show that soon.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Can I ask a question?
Oh, yeah.
Quickly.
Do you have any insight on what is the genomic scarings that you see in
prostate versus the other three
relevant tumor subtypes for these HRD signals?
Yeah.
Off the top of my head, I think the main thing that stuck out to me was
LOH signatures were a little bit different than the other cancer
types. I think it might have
been the extent of LOH or the segment sizes, but I think LOH was one
particular
output of our copy number calling that seemed distinct in that cancer type.
The distribution of the scores were a little bit different.
But yeah, I think we have to
define that more clearly.
Mm-hmm. Did you see also something on the mutational signatures side of it, or
just copy number, would you say?
Yeah. I'd say prostate has a distinct SAV signature as well.
SBS3 and SBS39 were the most clear in
breast and ovarian. So I think we still need to collect more samples and
look clearly at what
specific patterns prostate has in that way.
Thank you.
Yep.
Okay. At this point, I'd like to
introduce my next speaker, which is Jisun So,
who will be talking about integrated multi-omic approaches in
resectable hepatocellular carcinoma with microvascular
invasion for revealing therapeutic targets.
Thank you for the introduction. Today, I'm going
to present on integrated multi-omics approach in
resectable hepatocellular carcinoma with
microvascular invasion for revealing therapeutic targets.
Microvascular invasion refers to the presence of cancer
cell infiltrating into
blood vessel and hepatocellular carcinoma with MVI is
characterized by aggressive and rapid proliferation.
MVI is a significant clinical feature associated with
a high risk of recurrence and poor prognosis in
hepatocellular carcinoma.
However, it can currently only be
identified through histological examination of tissue.
There are no established biomarkers for MVI, and no
methods have been developed for its early detection.
As a consequence, standard treatment are
applied.Therefore, it is necessary to
identify the biological
characteristic of MVI and to explore
biomarkers for its early non-invasive
detection, as well as to discover MVI's specific
therapeutic targets.
From transcriptomic data annotated with MVI
status, gene expression profiling was applied
in the discovery code to identify a gene
signature associated with MVI. Based on this
signature, genomic prediction was performed using the
PSSP algorithm,
generating an MVI prediction score.
The prediction performance of this model was validated across
five independent external cohorts using the
PSSP algorithm. To investigate the biological
characteristic of MVI,
single sample gene set enrichment analysis, cell doubling time
analysis, and in silico analysis were performed.
In addition, to identify potential therapeutic targets,
correlation analysis were performed using the prediction score.
1,028 MVI signatures were identified
through gene expression profiling.
In the TCGA cohort, both macro and
microvascular invasion groups show
significantly higher prediction score compared to the
non-MVI group.
This finding demonstrates that the identified genomic
signature can be reliably utilized for MVI
prediction.
For indirect validation, a significant
association was identified between the MVI
signature and patient prognosis.
When examining the characteristic of HCC
with MVI, distinct patterns were observed depending
on MVI status in the discovery cohort.
In patients with MVI, cell cycle progression
was enhanced and bioacid metabolism
was reduced, indicating separation of liver specific
metabolic function, which corresponding to a more
aggressive subtype.
Oncogenic signaling also appeared to be
activated. Overall, in HCC with MVI,
the observed pattern is constant with aggressive tumor
behavior characterized by enhanced cell cycle
activity and suppressed hepatic metabolic
function.
External cohort were also identified a
characteristic pathway.
The hallmark pathway analysis revealed that cell cycle related
pathway include G2M checkpoint, E2F
targets, and MYC targets,
were strongly associated with
MVI prediction score. This finding indicate that enhanced
MVI characteristics were linked to increased cell cycling
rates.
To further validate these findings, cell doubling time was
analyzed using primary cell cycle
cultures derived from patient tumors.
It could be inferred that higher MVI prediction score was
associated with increased proliferation rate for
hepatocellular carcinoma cells.
Furthermore, to investigate the pathological roles driven by
transcription factor within the three MVI associated
hallmark pathway, in silico analysis was performed.
As shown above, this pathway includes seven key transcription
factors.
Our research indicate that these transcription factors
are implicated
in MVI related characteristic
including
EMT, metastasis, and vasculogenesis.
Next, the following section discuss strategies for
treatment of MVI.
Using IMbrave
150 data, which include patient
treated
with atezolizumab, overall survival
and progression free survival were
evaluated. Patients in the score high group
demonstrate poorer outcomes, suggesting that immune
checkpoint-based therapies may be less effectiveness in
this population. Similarly, drugs
commonly used in second and third line treatment of
hepatocellular carcinoma also appeared to
have limited efficacy in MVI positive cases.
This finding indicated that MVI is
associated with reduced treatment responsiveness,
highlighting the need to identify novel therapeutic
strategies optimized to this aggressive disease
phenotype.
To explore potential patient biomarkers, analysis were
performed based on serum protein expression.
Correlation analysis between serum protein expression and
the MVI prediction score identified six
significant biomarkers. As shown
in the right panel, a model using only these six
biomarker achieved a performance of
0.856. In comparison, a
model
incorporating in clinical established indicator,
albumin and bilirubin, demonstrates superior performance.
This research suggests that the combination of six
selected serum biomarkers with albumin and bilirubin may
serve as useful non-invasive approach for MVI
diagnosis.Next, to identify
potential therapeutic targets, Prism and
CRISPR data set from DNA-MAP were used.
The Prism data set provides information on drug sensitivity,
while the CRISPR data set provides information
about gene dependency. The analysis was
performed by calculating the correlation and slope
between each data set and the MBI prediction score.
In both Prism and CRISPR-based viability metrics,
genes exhibiting large negative values were
considered potential
therapeutic targets. Among the candidate genes highlighted in
the graph, TOP2A consistently
emerged as a therapeutic target. Subsequently,
inhibitors of TOP2A that can work
effectively were investigated.
As a result, analyzing drug sensitivity for the
top three drugs, it was found that it could work
significantly in the patient group with MBI
characteristics. Doxorubicin was identified as the most
effective agent. This
suggests its potential utility in
treatment of hepatocellular carcinoma with MBI.
In conclusion, hepatocellular carcinoma with patients with
MBI are characterized by an
increase in cell cycle pathway activity, leading to
accelerated tumor proliferation, as well as
pathological features such as EMT, metastasis, and
vasculogenesis. Biomarker capable of predicting
this MBI-associated molecular subtype was
identified, with TOP2A highlighting as a potential
therapeutic target. Targeting TOP2A may enhance
treatment efficacy and represent a potential
strategy of advancing
precision medicine in MBI positive
hepatocellular carcinoma.
Thank you.
Yes.
We have a question from the audience, please.
Mm-hmm. Thank you for your great talk. I have one question.
In a discovery cohort with MBI information, pathological
differences could be seen depending on the
presence. But how did you get characteristic pathway
be extracted through external cohort without MBI
information?
Thank you for the good question. As you mentioned,
in the discovery cohort, we conduct a T-test
using information on the presence of the MBI
to see difference in expression of pathway.
However, in external cohort without MBI
information, the correlation with
MBI prediction score and pathway was used.
Thank you.
We have another question over here. Yes.
Thank you for your presentation.
I have one question for you. In that MAP data, the
Prism data is based on the drug sensitivity, and the CRISPR
is based on the gene dependency. How did you extract
the list of gene targets from Prism as well?
Thank you for the question.
The Prism data of DNA-MAP provides drug sensitivity,
and CRISPR data shows genetic dependency.
The Prism itself does not directly drive
gene target, but it used known MOA
and target information for each drug together.
First, based on the target list of drugs, we
drive common important genes and select them
as therapeutic targets candidates.
After that Prism data was used,
confirmed the sensitivity to drugs that
inhibit the targets, and the doxorubicin was derived
as a major candidate in the progress.
Thank you.
Okay. I'd like to thank you for that talk.
I'd like to introduce our next speaker.
This is Mrunal Deshmukh who's going to be talking
about stromal immune composition significantly
contributes to adenomas polyp recurrence or
progression to cancer.
Thank you for having me. My name is Mrunal, and I'm presenting our findings on the
spatial markers that significantly contribute to recurrence of
polyps or their progression to cancer.
Colorectal cancer is a global problem with 1.8 million
new cases and 900,000 deaths every year worldwide.
Incidence of early onset colorectal cancer is also on the rise globally,
and in fact, it is the leading cause of cancer death among men
less than 50 years of age in the United States.
95% of colorectal cancer cases arise from
adenomatous polyps, and while malignant transformation
of polyps can take many years, certain polyps,
roughly five to 10% of polyps with features such as
larger in size than one centimeter, Villous or serrated histology,
or high-grade dysplasia, can transform into cancer.
Colonoscopy with polypectomy reduces the incidence and mortality
from colorectal cancer. However, roughly half the number of patients
who undergo colonoscopy also experience recurrence of
polyps in the same location, which is why they are put into
surveillanceHowever,
the period or the interval of surveillance is currently driven by
morphological features, which is an imperfect metric.
This brings us to the clinical utility and the concept of polyp outcome
phenotypes.
Briefly, a polyp could have three outcomes.
First, a polyp that was seen at the very first time during index
colonoscopy undergoes removal, and when that patient
is put or is scheduled for ongoing
surveillance, the polyp is not seen to have recurred in the
same location, making this the non-recurring outcome.
Second, it is possible that the polyp that was seen at the very first time, which
was removed during the index colonoscopy,
is seen to recur at the same location during ongoing surveillance
but has not progressed to cancer, making this the recurring
polyp with cancer-free outcome. Finally, it is possible
that a polyp that was seen
and removed during index colonoscopy can undergo recurrence,
but at some point it can also finally transform to cancer, making it the
POP-CRC or the cancerous outcome.
The goal of studying these polyp outcome phenotypes
is to provide precision prediction, which is to identify molecular
differences between polyps at the very first time that these
polyps were removed during index colonoscopy, despite
sharing similar morphological features.
To further understand precision prediction, I will be walking us through five sets
of results today.
The first one is comparing the polyp that progressed to cancer to the polyp
that did not recur to understand signs of progression.
The second is comparing the polyp that progressed to cancer to the recurring
polyp that did not progress to cancer.
The third is comparing the cancer-free outcomes, the recurring polyp to the
non-recurring polyp, to understand signs of recurrence.
The fourth is actually looking at the mutually shared
features between the polyp that progressed to cancer and the polyp that
recurred but did not progress to cancer to look for signs of abnormality in
the first polyp tissue that was removed during index colonoscopy.
And finally, the fifth one is uniquely looking at the features
in the polyp that turned to cancer compared to both the
cancer-free outcomes.
The method we are using to study precision prediction, one of the methods
is spatial transcriptomics using nanoString geomics.
We have profiled roughly between six to 12 donors for each of
the polyp outcome phenotypes. And for each of the donors, we are
profiling multiple regions from the first polyp.
Further, those regions are spatially resolved using the PanCK
stain. So PanCK positive are the green regions, which mark the
epithelial cells. And PanCK negative are the surrounding red
region, which marks the stroma or the tumor, or
the microenvironment around these epithelial cells that include
fibroblasts, endothelial cells, immune cells, and macrophages.
Diving into the first result that is comparing the polyp that progressed to cancer
to the polyp that did not recur, we see a reduction of
expression in the immune defense gene and also in the
MUC2 gene, which is responsible for intestinal barrier function
in the epithelial and the stromal compartments.
When we are looking at the cell type abundances, each dot here represents
multiple regions from multiple patients.
When we are looking at the differences in the cell type abundances, we see that the
polyp that progressed to cancer shows poor mucosal immune
protection due to reduction of the IgA plasma cells, IgM
plasma and macrophages, and also due to the reduction in the chemokine
signaling pathway.
Along with this, we also see a gain of stem cell-like properties
marked by the increase in the TUFT cells and the cells expressing claudin-10
plus, along with a decrease in the apoptotic signal.
In the stromal compartment, in the polyp that progressed to
cancer, we see reduced mucosal antigen surveillance and
compromised intestinal barrier marked by the reduction of
microfold cell proportion, along with reduced differentiation
marked by the PPAR signaling.
From the second result, when we are comparing the polyp that progressed to cancer
to the recurring polyp, but it did not progress to cancer, we
again see a reduction of expression of these immune defense genes,
along with a reduced expression of epithelial differentiation marked by
PHGR1 and downregulation of
FAP1 that is responsible for enterocyte and colonocyte
differentiation.
When we are looking at the pathways, we see a loss of metabolically
active immune compartment and differentiated epithelial compartments
marked by a reduced signal of glycolysis and oxidative phosphorylation
in the polyp that progressed to cancer, and also reduced breakdown
of the branched-chain amino acids, which is linked to development and progression
of polyps. In the stromal compartment, we see reduction of the base
accession repair, pointing to more oxidative damage and
mutation accumulation, and reduced homologous recombination,
pointing to the polyp that progressed to cancer being repair impaired
and genomically unstable.
In the third result, where we are comparing the cancer-free outcomes, the
recurring to the non-recurring polyp, we see again a
downregulation of the immune genes, along with loss of
intestinal protective barrier program marked by downregulation of
MUC2 and poor differentiation marked by downregulation of
KRT20.
When we are looking at the differences in the cell type abundances, we see reduced
mucosal barrier protection marked by the reduction of IgA
plasma cells and macrophages, along with more stem cell-like
and proliferative states, again marked by the transit-amplifying cells, the
stem cells, TUFT cells, and reduced apoptotic
signal. In the stroma, we see that the polyp
that recurred showed compromised intestinal barrier
protection due to reduction of the microfold cells abundance and
also altered metabolism and differentiation function due to
reduction of the PPAR signaling.When we are looking
at the features that were shared mutually by the polyps that
recurred but did not progress to cancer and the polyp that recurred but did
progress to cancer, we again see
poor mucosal immune protection marked by reduction of
IgLL5, downregulation of IgHM, and fewer IgA
plasma cells and macrophages. And in the stroma, we see increased
expression of MCT2B, which is an oncogenic driver in
non-small cell
lung carcinoma.
Reduced expression of KRT20, marking poor differentiation,
reduced expression of MUC2 gene marking reduced colon protective barrier,
and reduced mucosal antigen surveillance by fewer
microfold cells. Finally, when we are looking at the features that were
uniquely seen in the polyp that progressed to cancer, comparing to both
of the cancer-free outcomes, we again see reduced immune
surveillance and reduced epithelial
differentiation marked by PHGR1, reduced enterocyte and colonocyte
differentiation marked by FAP1, and reduced branching acid
breakdown. In the stromal compartment, again, we see
reduced IgLL5 pointing to lower
antibody and plasma producing capacity, along with a weaker
capacity to transport those antibodies into the lumen, and
altered metabolism marked by oxidative phosphorylation.
To summarize, I want to reiterate that we see these observations in the
very first polyp tissue that was resected during index colonoscopy.
In the non-recurring polyp, we see intact epithelium and balanced
stroma. In the polyp that recurred but did not progress to cancer,
we see reduced barrier protection, reduced immune surveillance,
and mild proliferation along with epithelial plasticity.
And in the polyp that progressed to cancer,
we see a higher immune defense loss, lower
differentiation, more stemness and proliferative state,
along with an altered stroma. And this was in the polyp that was removed
at the very first time,
many months or many years before it turned to cancer.
This gives a model of spatially resolved markers and
mechanisms that can be studied from the index colonoscopy,
which could help stratify patients for better surveillance
intervals to address recurrence and to identify
targets for preventing its progression to cancer.
I want to acknowledge Dr. Boardman for
giving me this opportunity and her excellent mentorship, and all members of the
Boardman lab, our collaborators, and our funding sources as well.
Thank you.
Thank you very much. I have a question.
So you've seen
very interesting patterns of the different markers in the
polyps that progress and the
ones that don't or they recur or they progress.
So what do you think are the next steps to combine this
information and convert it into a combined biomarker that will
give you a probability of progression so that then can be used in the clinic?
So if you can comment a little bit more how we use that information
to have an actionable
biomarker.
Right. I think we are working on
having a
clinical panel that we can
put into use, like for translational purposes.
Recently, Dr. Boardman did receive the funding from Mayo Clinic
Ventures, and we are currently working on
extracting more tissues for these purposes
exactly, and that is actually ongoing currently.
Thank you.
Okay. If there are no other questions, thank you-
Thank you
... for a wonderful presentation.
Thank you.
I'd now like to introduce Yong-Jun Cha, who will be talking about
"Clinical Validation of Whole Exome Sequence-Based HRD
Scoring and Its Prognostic Value for PARP Inhibitor
Maintenance in Ovarian Cancer."
Yeah. Thank you for your introduction, and
good afternoon, everyone. I'm Yong-Jun Cha from IMBDx,
and I'm very honored to speak here on behalf of our colleagues.
And today, I will present our clinical validation study of whole
exome sequencing based HR scoring and its positive
value for PARP inhibitor maintenance therapy in ovarian cancer.
Here are my disclosures.
So homologous recombination deficiency, HRD, is an established
biomarker response to PARP inhibitor maintenance
in epithelial ovarian cancer. And currently, it guides the
treatment selection for two PARP inhibitor regimen, olaparib
plus bevacizumab or niraparib in the first-line maintenance
setting.
In the current practice, however, HRD is
currently assessed mostly by a dedicated single-purpose
assay,
which is seen
separately from comprehensive genome profiling or germline
profiling.
And that means that patient need multiple testing and more
tissue and time and a longer workflow.
So we reasoned that the integrated paired tumor
normal whole exome sequencing would consolidate
comprehensive genome profiling and germline testing and HRD
assessment in single assay. And in this study,
we evaluated the clinical validity of our whole exome sequencing
based HRD scoring in an independent ovarian
cancer cohort.So this is a single
institution retrospective biomarker study at Seoul National University Hospital,
consisting of 81 patients who either received
the PARP inhibitor or bevacizumab as maintenance therapy
in the first-line or second-line treatment.
And we mainly examined the progression-free
survival in the first-line and second-line maintenance
therapy
according to the HRD scoring.
And as you can see, half of the patients received the upfront neoadjuvant
chemotherapy followed by interval debulking surgery, and another half
received
primary debulking surgery upfront.
And for each patient, we performed the tumor germline whole exome
sequencing CGP, called the cancer profiler,
on tumor FFPE and PBMC,
and our HRD scoring with some LOH and TAI
and LSD scores, and we defined
those having more than 50 as HRD-High.
And apart from HRD scoring, we also
called the BRCA status
as part of our whole exome sequencing based
CGP, and BRCA mutation was defined as
pathogenic germline with somatic mutation or large genomic rearrangement.
And for further analysis, we also used the current
HRD positive definition,
which is either HRD-High or BRCA mutation.
So a quick note on the HRD scoring. We used the modified
scar HRD-based workflow in which the whole exome sequencing-derived tumor
fraction was incorporated into upstream copy number inference,
which improves the calling stability, especially at low tumor
purity.
And we used the HRD high cutoff of 50,
because in our internal development cohort across
cancers with multiple histology, including ovarian cancer
and also treatment-naive breast cancer, cutoff of 50
showed more robustly disconnected BRCA-associated phenotype
and also aligned better with the clinical outcomes.
And also is
in line with another recent publication using
a very similar whole exome sequencing-based HRD assay.
In that study,
HRD high cutoff of 50 actually corresponds to the clinical validity
to my choice to the CDx cutoff of 42.
So turning back to the patient population, the median age was
56, and most patients had high-grade serous and Stage
3 or 4 tumor.
And for the
main analysis set, there is a patient with
first-line and second-line maintenance therapy.
Most of patients, there is 87
patients and 65 patients in the
first and second line received a PARP inhibitor as maintenance therapy,
and bevacizumab in the remaining population.
A quick look at the overall genomic landscape.
As you can see, TP53 was the dominant alteration, and most
patients nearly universally had the TP53 alteration, and
with recurrent events in BRCA and other
HR spectrum mutations.
And looking at distribution of whole exome
sequencing HRD score,
you can see the two-third of patients was defined as
HRD-High, and around half are
found to have a BRCA mutation. And as you can see,
the
HRD scoring showed the bimodal distribution with the
separation at 50, and HRD-High
classification was significantly associated with BRCA mutation.
And across
the HRD scoring,
the clinical staging and
the exposure to neoadjuvant chemotherapy was modestly associated,
but overall,
apart from a BRCA
mutation, the genomic alteration pattern did not differ according to HRD
status.
And the key question is,
does
HRD score carry independent prognostic effect
in the first-line and second-line maintenance setting?
So we ran a multivariate Cox
regression model
just for the staging neoadjuvant chemotherapy and also residual
disease. And as you can see, in the first-line maintenance setting, a BRCA mutation
alone was associated with
favorable PFS, and
HRD score tended favorably but attenuated in the
setting. But in the second-line maintenance setting, the trend is
shift, and the BRCA mutation is no longer significant,
and HRD-High
became the dominant prognostic marker.
So
it seems that in the
first-line and second-line setting,
whole exome sequencing-based HRD scoring is
independent prognostic
for this marker.
And the next key question
is the treatment stratifying effect according to HRD
score in a PARP inhibitor first-line
maintenance setting. And as you can see in the Kaplan-Meier
curves
on the left, among patients with HRD-High, the
patient treated with the PARP inhibitor was
associated with significantly longer PFS compared to
bevacizumab.And also in the restricted
mean survival time analysis at 36 months,
those with a PARP inhibitor
therapy population, the HRD positive is
associated with a significantly longer
RMST gain, and it is also observed
in BRCA status. So in the first-line maintenance
setting,
both HRD scoring and BRCA mutation can
stratify PARP inhibitor benefit.
And the treatment stratifying effect according to HRD score
is more striking in the second-line maintenance setting.
And those with
HRD high, the Kaplan-Meier curve
of the PARP inhibitor showed
a more pronounced PFS benefit
compared to bevacizumab. And also in RMST
analysis,
showed a very similar profile, showing that
among PARP inhibitor therapy or HRD score,
showed a pronounced
RMST gain compared to HRD low. And
this is in line with the previously seen forest plot
in that HRD score
is more prognostic than BRCA mutation in the recurrent
setting.
So in conclusion, in our study, whole exome-based HRD
scoring provided independent prognostic
information for PFS in maintenance setting
in both first line and second-line epithelial
ovarian cancer, and also it stratified
relatively clinical benefit from PARP inhibitor maintenance compared
to bevacizumab. And I want to emphasize that the
HRD cutoff here is not universal, and optimal
HRD cutoff may need to be tailored to clinical genomic
context and outcome-based performance.
And we believe that paired tumor normal whole exome
sequencing enables comprehensive genomic profiling,
germline testing, and HRD assessment in a single testing.
And especially now when MRD assessment is very
important, this platform may also be streamlined to
tumor-informed MRD assessment.
Given the limitation of the study coming from small
single-center retrospective design, prospective validation in independent
cohort is warranted and is currently ongoing.
Thank you for your attention, and I'm happy to take any
question.
I have a question. You may have said it, but
does the data suggest, or was it your impression that the whole exome
sequencing-based HRD scoring was more
specific, more sensitive, or both?
Oh.
If response was the metric.
Yeah. Excellent question. And so we directly compared
our testing
with the Myriad assay, although the
benchmarking is currently ongoing.
But
the whole concept of the study is not just comparing
the performance of the HRD assay using whole exome
sequencing, but rather than integrating, we want to
emphasize that integrating workflow that combine
HRD testing and also comprehensive CGP with the whole
exome and germline testing is more
accessible, more affordable, and benefit more in the clinical
practice. So it's the concept of the study. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you. Could you say a little more about the next studies that you're
planning, this prospective validation and-
Yes.
-what it would require? Yeah.
Yes. So actually,
this whole exome
sequencing based
profiling CGP is
very associated with the tumor-informed assay,
and we are now conducting
the same
using this assay in the MRD
study in
multiple cohort, like the breast cancer,
endometrial, ovarian, and also colorectal cancer.
So
as part of the MRD study, we are conducting the prospective
validation of the whole exome CGP and HRD
performance. Yeah.
Thank you.
All right. Thank you so much for that talk.
We will move on to our next speaker,
Johan
Fehrman, who will be talking to us about the utility
of CA19-9 for the prediction of asymptomatic
pancreatic cancer among patients with new onset diabetes.
Cool. There we go.
Now, awesome. Thank you to the organizers for inviting me to present some of the
exciting work that we've been doing over the past couple of years, really aimed
towards the development of blood-based biomarkers for risk assessment,
early detection of pancreatic cancer. So I do have a couple disclosures.
I note these here, but before anything, I think it is
important to remind ourselves that despite being a fairly
rare disease, pancreatic cancer is stillAmong
the leading causes of cancer-related mortality in the world, being
fourth and third in men and women respectively,
and that despite seeing overall
reductions in mortality due to cancer,
pancreatic cancer is actually one of the few cancer types where we've actually
seen an increase in mortality.
And this is in part attributed to the fact that
unfortunately, still today, the vast
majority of people who go on to be diagnosed with pancreatic
cancer will present at advanced stage disease when
outcomes for these patients is particularly dismal.
So one may ask, "Well, why do we not actually screen for pancreatic cancer?"
Well, it's a very rare disease, right?
The incidence is about 13.8
persons per 100,000 individuals in the
average risk population. In other words, you would need
to screen 7,246
individuals to find one pancreatic
cancer case.
It's a lot of screening, and this is not without consequence.
There are harms when you screen for pancreatic cancer
in a general population. There's anxiety.
There is concern over false positives and potential for
over-diagnosis that can occur in this population, and
that is why the United States Preventive Services Task Force
says, "Do not screen." They give it
a D because the harms outweigh the
benefits, with the exception that screening may be of
benefit towards higher risk populations.
And this is something that we and my team have really been trying to
tackle, to develop simple
cost-effective blood tests to identify those individuals who
are at high risk of developing disease
in the future as an enrichment tool, particularly something that can be employed in
the general population, or to identify biomarker tests that can
inform upon the presence of disease
to enable earlier detection. Now, I will say I've been doing this for
quite some time, and what is just represented here is sort of a
chronological of the work that we have done to develop
these sort of tests. Again, with the intention of identifying high-risk
individuals who will go on to develop pancreatic cancer or to detect pancreatic
cancer at an early stage. We have looked at this in the context of the general
population as well as higher risk populations.
And much of our work to date has really been focused in that pre-diagnostic
setting, right? To look in individuals who go on to develop
pancreatic cancer in the future. As I mentioned, we have sort of two
types of tests that we focus on, those that are intended to
identify individuals at high risk of developing pancreatic
cancer in the future, and those tests that are intended to detect the presence
of pancreatic cancer. And with respect to the latter, much of our work has really
centered on a simple three-marker protein panel consisting of
ALGY1, TIMP1, and CA19.9, wherein we
demonstrated that this three-marker protein panel provides superior
predictive performance for detecting early-stage pancreatic cancers compared to
CA19.9. And when we did a blinded validation
study of this fixed panel, we were able to replicate this exact same
observation, both with respect to the overall predictive performance, but
importantly, also seeing that improvement in sensitivity at meaningful regions of
specificity. And this was also the impetus that then allowed us to
go into the pre-diagnostic setting.
Now, we are very fortunate to have samples collected within five
years of a pancreatic cancer diagnosis from the prostate, lung, colorectal, and
ovarian, or the PLCO cohort. And one of the seminal findings that we had
in the context of this cohort was that you can actually see an appreciable
rise in CA19.9 two years
before a clinical diagnosis of pancreatic cancer, and that when you get into
samples collected within one year, you see this exponential rise,
right? But that even if you focus on those individuals that went on to be
diagnosed with respectable disease at six months prior, you can
still catch about 50% of these. We also showed in the study
that for those individuals that were low for CA19.9, the inclusion of
TIMP1 and ALGY1 can improve that sensitivity by about 13%
without loss of specificity. Now, this was also the study that gave
us the impetus to ask a different question.
Because we know that there's that appreciable rise, one could ask,
"Well, what happens if you consider the trajectory?" Right?
I think oftentimes people think of a single measurement, a single cut point.
But what about that rise? Can you leverage that?
Of course, those of you that are familiar with ovarian cancer, this is the basis of
the ROCA algorithm, where a rise in CA125 actually informs
upon risk of having disease. So we applied this exact same metric.
Using an independent set of serial samples from the PLCO cohort, we
applied an adaptive algorithm that looks at repeat CA19.9 testing,
and again, we asked a simple question: Can we improve the sensitivity?
Can we improve the lead time? And the short of it is,
yes and yes. So if you apply a longitudinal algorithm that
considers repeat CA19.9 testing, you can improve
the overall predictive performance on the base of AUC by about 6%, but
importantly, you can also increase that lead time detection by about an
additional six months.
And when you think about something like pancreatic cancer, that timing
matters.
Now on the basis of this, of course, this is in the context of the general
population, but as the presentation alludes to, we're obviously
focusing on new
onset diabetes. Now, this is a rather intriguing population.
Now, certainly it is known that very often when people are diagnosed with
pancreatic cancer, they typically have concurrent diabetes.
It is also now being increasingly recognized that those individuals
presenting with new onset diabetes, that a portion of
them might actually have occult disease that is
the causeOf the diabetes. And that
among new onset diabetics, there's about a 1%
probability that they will have a clinical diagnosis of
pancreatic cancer within three years.
Now, again, we are very, very fortunate.
We, in collaboration with a consortium of chronic pancreas
diabetes and pancreatic cancer, or the CPDPC, we
submit an ancillary study to get access to their nod cohort.
And we are very fortunate because not only did they give us access, but they
actually gave us all the blood specimens from the
2,270 nod participants that completed that three-year
follow-up period. So the entire specimen set was around
6,809 samples.
And one of the really, really neat aspects of this cohort is not only
does this contain pancreatic cancers, but it also contains other cancer types that
are prevalent among this population.
Now, this was a blinded validation study, so we
received the samples, we ran our biomarker tests, we applied
cutoffs based off 1% one-year risk.
This is what we believe would be clinically meaningful among this
population. We sent the data back to the data management coordinating
centers, and then they told us how we did.
So again, this is a true blinded validation study.
So, a couple interesting things about this particular cohort.
So again, as I mentioned, there were about 2,263
participants. Now, there were 12 pancreatic cancer
diagnoses that occurred within this population.
So this is a three-year instance of about 0.57%, about
eightfold higher than what you would observe in the general
population. And again, our fundamental goal is
can we find those 12 pancreatic cancer
cases among those 2,263 participants?
So if anyone's familiar with "Where's Waldo?" I kind of give this analogy,
right? So you have this nice view. You see all these people, and the question is:
Where's Waldo?
You have a second if anyone wants to know. Waldo's right there.
This is the fundamental goal. Can we find a Waldo in the context of
this population? So how did we do?
And I would say we actually did really, really well. So consider this.
CA19.9, this is a clinically available marker.
Granted, it is not used in a screening setting.
CA19.9, in the context of this co-population,
had an overall sensitivity of 83%
with greater than 97% specificity.
Right? And if you look at the people that were positive just for
CA19.9, there was actually a subset of them that
tested positive one year
before they were clinically diagnosed with pancreatic cancer.
And if we really break this down a little bit further, so again, one of the cool
parts of this cohort is not only did we have pre-diagnostic blood,
but we also had serial pre-diagnostic blood from individuals that went on to
develop pancreatic cancer. So again, we can ask this question of what is the actual
behavior and what is the lead time?
And what this figure represents here is each node represents a
sample from a given participant that went on to develop
pancreatic cancer. The connecting lines show the same individual, so you can look
at the trend of CA19.9. And I think you will
appreciate that quite a few of these individuals
had the first positive test on the basis of
CA19.9 upwards of nine months before a
clinical diagnosis. And then you ask, well, what about the
two cases that we missed? Well, interestingly enough,
one of these,
there we go, was actually picked up with our longitudinal algorithm.
And this is a really nice thing where you can see this.
So they had three samples, and it was negative, negative, still
negative based off a single threshold.
But on the basis of that rise, we actually flagged them to say, "You know what?
You are at elevated risk, and you might actually have the disease."
And the one case that we missed had a single blood draw that was
36 months, three years before a clinical diagnosis.
And I would make the argument that had we had another blood specimen
from this individual, it is very likely that we may have picked them up.
Right? So on the basis of the nod cohort and on the basis of the work that we've
done to date, what would this mean clinically?
Well, I would argue that the data that we have generated
would certainly support utility of CA19.9 as
part of routine testing for individuals presenting with
new onset diabetes.
And that there might be some benefit for additional markers, including things like
LG1 and Temp1, for identifying those individuals
who may not produce adequately high levels of CA19.9
for improved sensitivity.
And I'm happy to say I stuck within time, so that's good for me.
With that, I would like to give acknowledgement to the team.
This obviously takes a village. I have had truly a pleasure of working
with some of the great people in this field, including Anirban Maitra, who I saw
coming in here somewhere. So thank you, Anirban,
as well as really a wonderful team.
And again, I want to thank the organizers for giving me the opportunity
to share some of this exciting data.
Hello. Great work. And so one of the biggest confounders of
creating these specific tests is
pancreatitis, cholangitis, colitis, all obstructive
jaundice. And so when you do your comparisons against healthy controls,
it's kind of underestimating what your real-world sensitivity and
specificity issues are going to be.
So how does your test perform in that more challenging comparison against these
benign conditions that have higher incidents but the same biomarkers?
Yeah. So that is very relevant. Very good question.
General idea is, do we consider benign conditions that are prevalent in the
general population that may not be reflected in probably what you see in most
studies? And I would argue this is the beauty of the nod, because we
includedAll the patients, which means any comorbidity,
anything else that may occur in this population was represented.
And even then, we still achieved 83%
sensitivity at greater than 97% specificity.
So this would include patients that might present with these other cases.
But that is a very valid point.
Great presentation. Thank you. You mentioned in your concluding slides that
you think your other two markers will improve sensitivity.
Have you already measured them?
Surely, you must have.
We have. Yeah. So I figured somebody would ask that question.
It's really hard to beat, say, 19.9 when it effectively picked
everyone up. So the short of it is they did perform.
We just could not beat CA19.9. If you considered a single threshold in the
longitudinal,
we essentially caught every single one.
And like I had mentioned, the only one that was missed had a blood three years
prior, and everything was flat then.
So it's a good problem to have, is one way of looking at it. Yeah.
Nice presentation. I think this question many
people have asked this one so much.
In my mind,
CA19-9 is very sensitive to late stage of pancreatic cancer.
So how was the stage
when you identified the cancer by CA19-9?
Yeah. So obviously, because patients with NOD are not
undergoing screening, the vast majority of patients are presenting with advanced
stage disease, about 70%. This is typically what you find in the general
population as well.
But I will make two points. One, there were two early-stage cases, so that is
to say, individuals with resectable disease.
Both of these were positive for CA19.9 before a clinical diagnosis.
For the individuals that presented with metastatic or Stage 4 disease,
two of them actually had a positive signal well over a year before a clinical
diagnosis. So I would make the argument, although we don't know this definitively,
that at that point in time, it is likely that they probably did not have metastatic
disease, and that it would've been more localized.
Nice talk. So about the biomarker
CA19-9,
sometimes,
in other cancer type, it may also be high, such as gastric cancer.
So
specifically, your control is based on just health control.
How do you know
all those cancer are pancreatic cancer? Yeah, that's my question. Yeah.
Yeah. So great question. So again, one of the unique portions of the NOD cohort is
we had all the other prevalent cancers.
That specificity actually includes the other cancer types.
So it's pancreatic versus anything else.
So even if you were to consider pancreatic cancer versus other cancer type, the
specificity was still quite high.
Now that being said, it is 100% true that GI-centric cancers,
including upper GI and even potentially colorectal cancer, can have elevated
levels of CA19.9. But I also make one general claim.
The goal here of CA19.9 is not to diagnose.
It is intended to identify individuals at very, very high risk that should
really undergo surveillance and that may benefit from a targeted screening-based
modality. So I just want to throw that in there.
Okay, thank you.
Just on that point, I want to ask a quick question.
So, you showed some very nice data of the one patient that was missed
that actually had a
velocity or a tumor doubling time, and this is not dissimilar to what we think
about in prostate cancer with PSA doubling time.
So how do you envision capturing that
longitudinal change versus the threshold, and what would
be the appropriate
mix of the metrics?
Yeah. So right now
we have both. Obviously, there's a single threshold, and if you exceed
that, you're considered positive.
So obviously, the concept of longitudinal is, by definition, you
need at least two tests, and if you're negative, negative by single threshold,
that's really where the longitudinal algorithm would shine.
Again, this is very akin to the ROCA algorithm.
One way that we envision this is that somebody comes in, they present with NOD,
they get tested. Depending on that level, that would sort of dictate the
frequency. So if you're sort of borderline, I would say come back in six months.
If you're low, come back in a year, and as soon as we get the two points, then by
definition that algorithm kicks in. So I would say it's part of a package deal.
Yeah.
Thank you. I have-
Thank you
... another question about your... Sorry.
You're not allowed to leave yet.
So you evaluated
sensitivity and specificity of the test both in PLCO, which is general
population, as well as your
cohort with
new diabetes diagnosis. In PLCO, do you have information on
diabetes, and did it-
No
... make a difference? And that's one question.
The other, have you translated your estimate into
positive and negative predictive value in these populations?
The answer is yes and no. So unfortunately with the PLCO, they did not actually
count for nuance of diabetes. They do have cataloging of
long-standing diabetes. And even in that context, we did very, very
well. I will go a little bit on the side.
We've actually done some metabolic profiling on the PLCO cohort, and I can assure
you the NOD patients are there on the basis of their
metabolic phenotype, even though they're not clinically annotated to have as such,
right? Because that's a function of the follow-up and sort of the investigations.
With respect to PPV, we do have that as well.
In the context of NOD, the PPV was around 70%.
It was pretty high.
Thank you.
Thank you. All right. Thank you.
Thank you for that great talk.
I'm pleased to introduce our next speaker,
Wendy Cao, who will be talking about precision diagnostics for
early melanoma detection using spatial biology and
AI-guided image analysis.
Hello. So first of all, I need to apologize for me
constantly sneezing because I think San Diego is really too cold for
me as a Queenslander.
So for people who don't know where Queensland is, it's actually, we
call that a Sunshine State in Australia, and it's
also the melanoma capital of the worldSo
in Australia,
more than 300,000 melanocytic lesions were excised every
single year in suspicious of a melanoma.
And here in
America, the number is actually two million lesions.
So melanoma can be diagnosed based on the clinical presentation,
but sometimes a clinical presentation of benign nevus can
mimic the one as
the melanoma. So it really takes a clinician experience and
time to accurately diagnose a lesion.
So the gold standard of diagnosing a melanocytic lesion is actually through
histopathology assessment.
But this is a very lengthy, costly, and
subjective process. So it was actually estimated
that around 5% of the excised lesion in suspicious of a
melanoma actually turned to be a melanoma.
In other words, the hit rate is around one in 20.
So there is clinical guideline, such as MPATH, that try
to classify a melanocytic lesion into either benign or
malignant. But later on, there was another study
showing that
try to assess the MPATH validity, and in this
study, they showed that when a lesion is clearly benign or
malignant, the diagnostic concordance is really high.
But for intermediate lesion, like the one on the right-hand side here,
36 study pathologists actually give rise to 18 different terms for this
particular lesion, suggesting that there is a very high
interobserver variation in intermediate lesions.
So
in this project, we want to reach precision diagnostics.
We want to understand or give out
objective measure that can accurately diagnose the melanocytic
lesions. So we're working with two sample cohorts in this study.
The first one is retrieved from the local pathology
provider, SMP.
We have a total of 261 samples from this
cohort.
We profile some of them, including benign nevus, nevus with
low-grade atypia, nevus with high-grade atypia or of
diagnostic uncertainty, melanoma in situ,
melanoma arising from nevus, or thin invasive
melanoma.
We also include normal skin in this study because we want to know
what true normal is.
So we utilize visum cytosis
because basically this platform allows us to look at the spatial
distribution of gene expression whilst retaining the morphology from
H&E staining.
And for many of you might appreciate that
visum cytosis is a little bit expensive, so we
developed this multiplexing approach that fit in
a total of 17 samples in this 11 by 11 millimeter
capture array.
For people who are interested, you can scan a QR code to learn how to do
it.
So
you might also appreciate that visum cytosis is not a single-cell
resolution. So we really need a single-cell reference data
set that actually allow us to infer
the cell type information from the cytosis data.
So
we made a single-cell data set.
So in this integrated single-cell data sets, we have healthy skin,
benign nevus, and thin invasive melanoma, and
this data set has been annotated in detail.
But to keep my story short and sweet, I'll just focus on the level one
annotation here, and I really want to draw your attention to this
melanocytes population. We actually discover a
few melanocytic cell states, and they
do have their distinct gene expression profile in each
state.
So we perform deconvolution, and this is a case of
benign nevus, and this is a case of thin melanoma.
And we found this red
melanocyte populations that seem to be specific to benign
nevus, and this purple population seem to be
specific to thin melanoma.
So we perform binary comparison, comparing between benign
nevus on the left-hand side and thin melanoma on the right-hand
side. And we found that the red population
is actually clinically and statistically significant and higher
in the benign nevus as compared to thin melanoma.
And the purple melanocytic population is
actually expressed abundantly in thin melanoma as compared
to benign nevus.
We also perform target panel sequencing, looking at the BRAF
V600 mutations, and we found that this mutation is
highly expressed in the benign nevus as compared to thin melanoma.
So we want to validate this finding using Genome in Situ platform.
And so for people who missed the QR code scanning, you can
scan again to learn how to do multiplexing.
So we have a total of 19 samples in this two centimeter by one
centimeter capture array.
Just to quickly show you a case of benign nevus on the
right-hand side here and a case of thin melanoma at the bottom.
Spot deconvolution shows that the red melanocyte
population is actually confirmed to be enriched in
benign nevus, and the purple melanocytic cell states is
highly enriched in
melanoma.
So really, what are we looking at? So we want to
know what genes are expressing in the red melanocyte population and
the purple melanocyte population.
So we perform differentially expressed gene analysis from benign
nevus and thin melanoma.
We filter the genes based on these
criteriaAnd we identify 202 genes in the
benign nevus module and 106 genes in the malignant module.
So this is a module score analysis showing every single
sample, undergoing VZ-CyTOSYS, and
each grid here represents one sample.
So in our benign nevus, we see a very high level of
correlation with nevus module scores compared to thin melanoma.
And in the thin melanoma, we see a very high level of melanoma module
score compared to benign nevus.
Then where are they? So we profile where these genes
are expressing, so back to this nevus and melanoma case,
we profile the nevus module score and see that it's actually aligned with
the red melanocyte population,
and there's no nevus module score expression in a thin
melanoma. And when we profile
the melanoma module score spatially, we actually found that the thin
melanoma
region is enriched with this melanoma module score.
And we thought that maybe we can use this module score to improve the diagnostic
accuracy.
So basically we have all the intermediate lesion such as
nevus with low-grade atypia, and we see a very high level of
correlation with nevus module score.
On the other hand, nevus with high-grade atypia or
diagnostic uncertainty, we have higher correlation with melanoma
module score as compared to nevus module score.
And in melanoma arising, in association with nevus and
melanoma in situ, we actually have a higher
correlation with thin melanoma
module score as compared to the nevus module.
So just take this one case as an example.
This borderline case with diagnostic uncertainty,
we have the H&E here.
This is a deconvolution where we
observe a lot of purple melanocyte cell states.
We don't see anything from a nevus module score, and we see a very
high level of melanoma module score, suggesting that this lesion
indeed needs to be excised for future monitoring.
So we also send our matching sample to Harvard Medical
School, and Peter and Julia help us profile on the Orion platform.
So this is a Zenium data showing a case of
melanoma in association with a nevus.
And on the left-hand side, you see melanoma with enrichment of purple
melanocytes. On the right-hand side is a nevus with
red melanocytes.
Prime density shows that there's a very high level of
expression in the melanoma region as compared to nevus region.
And when we look at the protein level on Orion platform,
it's actually also highly enriched in the melanoma region as
compared to the nevus region.
So what else can we do?
In collaboration with Kwan and Shell in the QIMR
Berghofer Medical Research Institute, we provide them with our
VZ-CyTOSYS data, and we aim to train a
model
for gene prediction.
So basically, this is our CyTOSYS data.
We have the SOX10 expression and S100B expression
here.
We train the model and predict the SOX10 and
S100B expression on the same VZ data.
And as you can see here, the correlation is actually pretty high.
We can pick up the lesion region pretty accurately.
So what does this mean in a clinical setting?
So this is a case of benign nevus with three individual sections on the
same block, and this is a case of thin melanoma with three individual
lesions on the same block. And these two sections
have no spatial data.
So we can directly predict their gene expression from the
H&E slides, and from these data we can directly
tell that the regions highlighted in red represent the
region that needs to be
excised or
have further attention.
So in summary,
we see a limitation in diagnosing melanocytic lesions, so we
want to reach precision diagnosis in our project, and we
identify cell types and transcriptional cell states in benign and
malignant lesions. We also come up with these module
scores that allow lesion classification into either benign or
malignant. We also develop a computer-assisted
approach that predict gene expression directly from H&E image.
So with that, I want to thank my team for all the hard
work. Thank you.
Thank you.
I'd like to open it up to questions.
One
observation you had that I thought was interesting and somewhat counterintuitive
was that, if I'm not mistaken, you found an
increase or an enrichment for BRAF V600E in benign nevus,
which is the most common oncogenic mutation in melanoma.
So how do you reconcile that difference?
So
my supervisor, Mitch, a few years ago, he actually found
that every single nevus has either
BRAF or NRAS mutation.
So
this is what we're expecting.
Interesting. And so do you think that has then implications for
thinking about melanoma oncogenesis?
Because when we categorize,
biomarker-Testing for metastatic melanoma
oftentimes will include BRAF and NRAS testing
for both predictive and prognostic.
But how do you envision this sort of playing a role
in the... For example, in the melanoma cases you do identify, is there
some potential pathway looking at
high risk versus low risk as a future project?
Well, we can use this to know where the
origin is. For example, there is melanoma arising inside you, then we don't
see any BRAF mutation.
All right.
Let me close.
Well, I want to thank you for that wonderful talk.
Thank you.
And
I will give some remarks.
So first of all, I would like to thank the organizers at AACR for
inviting me to co-chair this session.
I am Tejas Patil. I'm a thoracic oncologist at the University of
Colorado Cancer Center, and I want to first of all thank all of our
speakers for their wonderful presentations.
In thinking about the closing remarks, I
was considering four themes that I think unify all of these
presentations.
And the first theme that we saw in these presentations was that biomarker
testing is moving upstream. There were several abstracts that were
focusing on predicting risk before clinical events.
So in abstract 415, we saw whole genome
duplication predicting future metastatic risk in a
pan-cancer cohort. In abstract 418, we saw
stromal immune features that predict polyp recurrence and progression.
In abstract 420, we saw the interesting use of
CA19-9 to predict occult pancreatic cancer in patients with
new onset diabetes. And finally, in the most recent presentation we
just heard from, we saw the use of spatial biology and potentially AI
to predict early melanoma invasion.
And I think the
first common theme that I had in this session was that biomarkers are shifting from
prognostic, meaning after metastatic disease, to predictive
before disease progression. And as we move these biomarkers
earlier, I think we can potentially move the needle in terms of thinking
about how to integrate some of these markers
in predicting metastatic recurrence
and even cancer emergence before clinical
progression. The second theme is that
a lot of these abstracts showcased that we need to move
beyond single gene biomarker testing to something that integrates
system-level biology.
In fact, most of these abstracts have moved away from single gene markers, and this
is relevant in thoracic cancer, where a lot of time is
spent thinking about the negative prognostic implication of something
like KEAP1, which is a known
negative marker that confers immune checkpoint inhibitor refractoriness.
But what we saw in these presentations is a move away from that.
So in abstract 415, we saw whole genome
duplication. In abstracts 416 and 419, we saw the novel use of
HRD genomic signatures. In abstract 417, we
saw 1,028 gene transcriptomic MBI
signature. And similarly, in abstracts 418 and
421, we saw novel uses of spatial imaging and spatial
monitoring to look at risk. And so another theme that
I got from this talk and this mini
symposium was that biomarkers are evolving from single mutation
assessments to multi-omic biology.
The third theme is using biomarkers to predict
aggressive biology and metastatic potential.
And what we saw in several of these talks was the innovative
use of early markers of aggressive disease.
Again, abstract 415, which was looking at whole genomic
duplication, but there were some very unique findings, especially in
the differences seen in the breast cancer cohort,
that were striking. In abstract 417, we saw an HCC
MBI signature, which is a known aggressive phenotype, and really trying
to think about how to integrate those into clinical management.
418 really highlighted the use of stromal immune features and very
nicely showed how to delineate high-risk polyps
from polyps that might have more benign outcomes.
And finally, in abstract 421, or in presentation
421, we saw melanoma invasive cell states really with the novel
use of spatial imaging. And this theme really
highlights the need to identify aggressive biology well before
clinical progression.
The fourth theme is something that we will hopefully see more of
in the coming years, which is the use of computational biology and
computational oncology to help think through
clinical biomarkers.
Several new computational approaches were shown today.
In abstract 416, we had really novel uses of HRD
prediction. In abstract 417, we had integrative multi-omics for
HCC. In abstract 420, a very nice detailed
discussion of Bayesian algorithms to look at CA19-9
monitoring. And then finally, in abstract 421, we had a novel
description of spatial imaging and spatial biology to help
define our clinical biomarkers. And so with that, I'd like to conclude this
session, and I would like to thank the audience for their wonderful questions.
Thank you.